The correct answer is blah equals the
list "one, 2 and now "th\" r\"
ee"]}. The main distinction between a Python object and a JSON representation of
a very similar object is that JSON has to use double quotes to
delineate a string. It can't use single quotes like Python does. So, you must
escape any internal double quotes. Alright, so this is basic JSON.
And as we've seen it maps very nicely to Python data structures,
assuming you're using integers and floats and strings. If you want
to map a more complicated Python structure 2 JSON, let's say you're
doing an object or maybe a date time or some other
things, the JSON dumps function isn't going to work for you. You're
going to have to actually convert those by hand to a simple
data structure made up of dictionaries, and lists, and integers, and strings
so that we can output it properly.